[Musique]
bonsoir à bata cagna merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france baisse du
nombre de contaminations
enfin les effets du confinement des
efforts consentis par les britanniques
et de la vaccination de masse selon vous
les deux combinés nom a il faut être
très clair c'est nombre de cas en
réduction c'est surtout dû aux
restrictions
donc lorsque des restrictions sont mises
en place que les gens ne vivent pas leur
vie ordinaire alors le nombre
d'infections laisse immunisés que les
populations plus vulnérables les
personnes les plus âgées
la baisse du nombre de cartons plusieurs
autres otages
si l'infini que bon cela est dû à la
restriction la réduction des
déplacements et non pas encore au vaccin
les frais de la vaccination interviendra
plus tard
alors on a bien compris un les cas
positifs baisse dans les cas de
contamination baisse
est-ce que les cas de décès baisse
également et peut-être que là on
pourrait ressentir les effets de la
vaccination puisque on le rappelle tout
de même quinze millions de britanniques
ont déjà été vaccinées ça fait beaucoup
de monde
yes aux baies cosby vaccinés la
vaccination s'est concentré sur les
personnes très vulnérables
que ce soit en raison de la rage de la
situation sanitaire
donc le taux de décès devrait bientôt
commencer à tomber également et les
personnes les plus âgées qui seront
contaminés pourraient ne pas mourir dans
l'avenir secteur je commence à constater
certains bénéfices
les gens semblent montrer une certaine
protection suite à l'injection du vaccin
il comptera que la maladie mais ne
développent pas de forme grave qui les
envoient à l'hôpital
est ce que vous constatez justement vous
sur le terrain des effets secondaires ou
globalement cette campagne de
vaccination se passe plutôt bien au
royaume uni le solde
les effets secondaires on s'y attendait
des douleurs au niveau de l'injection de
la fatigue des maux de tête pendant
quelques jours ce ne sont pas des effets
secondaires sérieux
autant que nous sachions certes il y à
certains cas mais en règle générale la
campagne de vaccination se déroule très
bien et l'une des raisons de ce succès
c'est que pour changer le gouvernement
du royaume uni à tirer parti à utiliser
les systèmes existants du nhs avec par
exemple des médecins généralistes
la leçon à retenir ici c'est que si l'on
se sert des experts locaux des gens qui
connaissent bien la situation alors il
ya de meilleurs résultats avec moins de
besoin alors les vaccins et les variants
aussi on les craint toujours d'ailleurs
un nouveau variant a été découvert
baptisé b15 25 ce n'est pas exactement
comme on le prononce un pour être
honnête
repérez également sur le territoire
français est ce que vous le connaissez
vous est-ce qu'il est plus virulent que
les autres concerts variés mais quand on
se doute qu'elle voudra paraître c'est
le fonctionnement naturel de ce type de
virus et en se multipliant en serait
plus qu il y à des heures et
ainsi le virus acquiert par ses erreurs
un avantage reproductif
alors cela rien devient à la forme
dominante en circulation donc je
souhaite bien dire aux gens ils peuvent
en être certain malgré le variant la
plupart des vaccins semble rester
efficace semble toujours protéger contre
de formes graves de la maladie
donc le vaccin reste protecteur malgré
les variants et le vaccin protège contre
le virus d'origine mais également contre
les variants empêche de développer des
femmes est grave
si le variant ses invariants très
différent apparaît alors nous pouvons
toujours changer la forme du vaccin afin
de mieux protéger contre ce variant
spécifiques
alors malgré un ses variantes dont vous
parlez
lueur d'espoir ça nous vient de l' oms
qui a affirmé il y avait hier que le
nombre de cas avait reculé 1 les quatre
qu'ovide de 16% sur une semaine
globalement dans le monde
comment doit-on prendre cette bonne
nouvelle avec prudence
oui il faut rester prudents il faut
reprendre cette expression qu'utilisent
année s'inscrit il ya très longtemps on
a bien qui signifie le monde est une
famille
nous devons rester unis et agir comme si
le monde
c'était une famille unique il ne suffira
pas d'ironiser tous les pays riches
d'europe et des états unis tout en
laissant de côté et l'afrique et l'asie
nous devons utiliser protéger toutes les
populations
en parallèle c'est ainsi que nous
aurions moins des variants et c'est
ainsi que le monde entier sera mieux
protégé contre les nouveaux variants
alors puisque vous parlez d'asie que
vous venez de citer à un problème
proverbe d'inde un dernier mot sur ce
pays comment expliquez-vous que l'un
d'eux soit plutôt épargné par cette
deuxième vague sans restriction dans le
pays
oui donc non c'est un mystère
scientifique et pourquoi se porte-t-elle
si bien si soudainement pour moi je
pense qu'il ya plusieurs facteurs tout
d'abord la population est plus jeune un
souhait qui sait peut-être que leur
système immunitaire est plus fort car il
est confronté à beaucoup d'eux
d'infection il ne faut pas oublier
également le soleil et il est également
possible que cela soit une modification
temporaire en vertu des températures à
cette période de l'année
donc effectivement l'inde a beaucoup de
chance pour le moment cela pourrait
changer très soudainement alors soit de
quoi évidemment on souhaite qu'il reste
dans cet état de grâce merci à baratte
up en khâgne un expert en maladies
infectueuses à l'université d'exeter
merci d'avoir été avec nous